retenez bien son nom Arthur Lorimier il
vient de Montigny-le-Bretonneux il va
participer en 2023 au championnat de
France junior de karting y participera
également au championnat d'Europe junior
de karting électrique nous avons la
chance de recevoir Arthur avec son père
Lionel sur ce plateau on l'a vu
précédemment alors Arthur est-ce que
c'est une grosse année 2023 en
perspective oui
car tout d'abord
je l'année dernière était un année
d'entraînement donc cette année je vais
tout faire pour viser le podium à chaque
course je vais découvrir l'électrique si
la première je pense que l'électrique ça
va
ça s'installe de plus en plus dans le
sport mécanique donc m'entraîner déjà à
changer de motorisation de pneus
de catégorie et tout ça ça
m'entraînement dans le domaine du
karting oui pourquoi parce que déjà le
couple maximum à l'accélération alors
qu'en termes il y a une courbe de
puissance
irrégulière et puis c'est pas les mêmes
cartes non plus en niveau poids
faut s'adapter très vite
alors Lionel en 2023 grosse année
comment on fait de vous pour
l'accompagner en tant que parents en
tant que parents on s'adapte franchement
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un agenda compliqué entre les
entraînements les courses il faut
jongler entre tout ça et puis du coup
les déplacements sont quand même assez
lointains puisque on va aller aussi bien
jusqu'au tout au nord de l'Angleterre
donc c'est quand même des gros gros
déplacements
nous nous présenter un petit peu votre
parcours Arthur là vous êtes passionné
de voiture depuis l'âge de 5 ans mais
c'est quand même assez récent finalement
cette entrée dans les dans les sports
mécaniques
donc j'ai débuté le karting à 10 ans
juste après le confinement donc à la SM
mentaise le karting par contre je
n'avais pas l'âge pour faire l'école de
karting qui permet tous les mercredis
après-midi de se retrouver avec les
animateurs et de d'apprendre par exemple
à freiner faire des zigzags etc donc
j'ai débuté le quart tout seul avec mon
propre carte son coach et au bout de six
mois j'étais déjà recordman de la piste
dans ma catégorie donc après j'ai fait
que l'améliorer jusqu'à passer en
National
cette année
début 2022 je rappelle que vous avez 12
ans et demi actuellement
Lionel vous n'êtes pas une famille de
pilote finalement pas du tout ni de
pilote ni autour de la compétition
automobile du coup on apprend en fait on
apprend et c'est vrai que c'est pas un
apprentissage facile parce que
finalement déjà 12 ans il faut
dire entre guillemets c'est déjà un peu
vieux parce que la plupart des
concurrents en fait qu'il affrontent ont
déjà entre 5 et 8 voire plus d'années
d'expérience alors que lui bah
finalement ce n'est que sa deuxième
année donc c'est c'est vrai que il faut
enfin il a fallu tout mettre en place en
fait moi j'ai aussi appris la mécanique
pour faire la mécanique avec lui quand
il a besoin de d'un mécanicien en
entraînement parce que c'est vrai qu'on
faut pas l'oublier c'est pour mécanique
c'est à la fois un pilote mais c'est
aussi une équipe mécanicien et autres et
un sac dans les pilotes très
expérimentés qui font ça depuis très
longtemps ils ont des équipes avec leur
mécano etc quand on dit que nous on est
relativement débutants donc on est on
est encore en entraînement en fait tout
seul on essaie d'avoir de plus en plus
l'aide d'un coach aussi pour pouvoir
l'aider à progresser mais c'est vrai que
c'est c'est toute une organisation à
voir c'est dur de rentrer dans ce monde
déjà c'est un tout petit monde enfin
tout le monde se connaît
oui c'est dur parce que déjà il faut que
je rattrape l'expérience que les autres
seront déjà acquises donc c'est c'était
l'année dernière j'ai tout fait pour
rattraper
l'expérience sur les départs en cours
comme en doubler
et alors à quel moment vous vous êtes
dit je vais faire du karting pour pour
le loisir et puis ensuite c'est passé a
vraiment je veux me spécialiser dans le
karting bah je veux presque en faire mon
métier plus tard à l'âge de 5 ans
j'avais déjà l'objectif de faire du
karting donc j'ai dû attendre jusqu'à 7
ans et demi pour pouvoir en faire
réellement en loisir mais faute de temps
j'ai pu commencer que à 10 ans et demi
donc le karting Loisir n'a rien à voir
en fait avec le karting de compétition
c'est c'est pas du tout les mêmes
vitesses c'est assez c'est assez
incroyable et
c'est vrai que en fait on en faisait un
peu en loisir précédemment mais
tout à l'heure en fait il y a des écoles
de karting qui sont finalement pour
entre les enfants entre 7 et 10 ans le
problème c'est qu'il faut les connaître
quand on n'est pas quand on n'est pas du
milieu en fait on les connaît pas leur
visibilité commence à s'améliorer mais
objectivement le nom de la prix trop
tard en fait
donc c'est vrai que c'est comme il l'a
dit comme disait Arthur c'est un petit
milieu mais quand on vient pas de ce
milieu là
il faut apprendre faut vraiment
apprendre au fur et à mesure et
ben on apprend aussi de ces erreurs donc
des fois voilà on a on a parfois perdu
un peu de temps mais Arthur avait le
talent pour pour justement rattraper ce
retard en fait qu'on avait qu'on avait
pris
et à 5 ans déjà tu savais que tu voulais
devenir pilote professionnel j'avais
déjà je regardais déjà les Grands Prix
de fin
justement est-ce qu'il y a une
préférence enfin quelqu'un qui qui vous
a inspiré Arthur un pilote j'ai trois
idoles j'ai mis Schumacher donc pour son
travail ça a détermination donc le
travail avec enfin elle était tout le
temps sur la piste c'est un peu lui qui
formait la voiture en fait c'est lui qui
dit que tu es au mécano comment
[Musique]
comment régler la voiture après j'ai
Jacques Villeneuve pour la triple
couronne et qu'il a failli avoir avec
sa deuxième place en endurant au 24
heures du Mans en 2008 et j'ai Lewis
Hamilton aussi pour
Karina en fait il n'a jamais baissé les
bras même s'il a tout tout réussi donc
il a 7 types de champion du monde il a
de victoires comme ça et il en veut
toujours plus un exemple du coup et au
niveau de votre plus belle expérience
Arthur alors vous avez participé à votre
premier championnat de France
d'endurancement c'était en 2021 c'est
vraiment l'un des meilleurs moments de
votre carrière pour l'instant vous
terminez sur le podium je crois
troisièmement du deuxième c'était les 90
minutes du Mans
en cadet c'était
dur déjà parce que tenir 15 minutes dans
le kart
en étant focalisé
[Musique]
j'avais encore du mal à
rester focus mais maintenant j'arrive à
rester focus pendant 20 30 30 minutes et
c'était l'une de ces premières courses
que vous avez été surpris de ces six
bons résultats des dès les débuts
totalement sur kiwi parce que c'est vrai
que c'est jamais évident en fait quand
on est dans des conditions de course on
a tout peut se passer et ça risque qui
m'a surpris c'est que finalement
il a fait que améliorer ses temps tout
le long de la course donc c'est c'était
aussi un signe que en fait plus plus
l'expérience venait aussi parce que
quand c'est la première course il y a
pas mal de choses auxquelles on a un peu
d'appréhension parce que ben on les
connaît pas forcément et on a bien vu
qu'à un moment donné c'était c'était
passé c'était devenu presque naturel et
du coup les tons continuent à tomber et
ça c'était vraiment super sympa et en
2022 vous intégrer la catégorie junior
au Kaiji alors où sont présents les
meilleurs pilotes âgés de 12 à 15 ans
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette catégorie
Arthur donc c'est une catégorie où les
moteurs déjà sont enfin c'est la seule
catégorie en France à avoir ces moteurs
là donc c'est organisé par la FFSA
Academy
qui est une école de karting et de F4 et
[Musique]
en fait c'est cinq courses dans l'année
on a un coach qui change toutes les
courses et donc tous les meetings les
coachs font
ils analysent les cours pour nous donner
les courbes des autres pour pouvoir
savoir où est-ce qu'il faut freiner plus
tard ou est-ce qu'il faut réaccélérer
plutôt ici quelle trajectoire est-ce
qu'on prend ici quelques trajectoire il
faut prendre
etc il y a plein de paramètres sur
lesquels les couches jouent donc ils
jouent dans ce championnat on touche pas
aux cartes donc il y a pas de réglage
moteur il y a pas de réglage châssis à
part l'élargissement des voies
donc c'est aussi pour les aider à
progresser et puis ce qui est aussi
sympa c'est que on cherche pas à
compenser une éventuelle
enfin une éventuelle
coup de moins bien du pilote par la
machine puisque dans d'autres catégorie
c'est un peu des fois la machine qui
fait que le bal pilote gagne aussi bah
là les résultats c'est vraiment le
pilote qui fait la différence puisque
c'est le même matériel pour tout ça et
tu roules jusqu'à combien de kilomètres
heure
j'ai fait 126 à Varennes et ça va la
vitesse te fait pas peur non
j'en demande plus
très bien et bien merci beaucoup Arthur
et Lionel laurigny d'être venu en
plateau avec nous du coup on suivra ta
carrière de très près